enjoy and i'm bing-bong knows in this
voice there's rich again i'm bing bong I
can't do Richard and Ed you know what
I'm anger that I can do that we know you
can't do that I can do and this is
sibling rivalry ever wonder what the
little voices inside your head are well
you know probably get look dad but in
this case it's uh your emotion star
turns out it's not neurosis it's cute
I'll give you both you be cute and
erratic fix our latest film personalizes
your emotions into five characters and
they go on this incredible adventure
making it sound like something to be so
big we personalize your mosaic solitude
that's kind of what they're doing
yes uh but uh my god do they do it well
um you know whatever somebody's asking
like in any of our other reviews I mean
really this into stashwick or anything
when I say I want something new I want
something fresh I want a new spin even
if it's on something we've seen before
just challenge us and do something
visual but it's also a dialogue why very
interesting and it's Martin as funny as
creative has fantastic characters this
is about as close to a perfect movie as
I can imagine honestly especially with
this concept what you wanted was a
retread of Herman's head success and
also actually Disney did kind of juice
us before it on there's a cartoon do you
remember the really sexist one like from
the 50s or whatever Luca von Drake
you remember that Ludvig bahoudii Kesari
doing von drake but um how dare insult
that real person's name oh actually no I
don't remember that you know it was you
know the guy's a point of view which is
like you know is that you're kind of
funny it's like this very sophisticated
guys doing mostly driving that just this
caveman
who's like waiting to break out and
they're like driving the guy oh my god I
totally know but those are you ripped it
on but then they go to the woman's head
and it's all about like you know the big
disasters that they overeat as like oh
no sometimes in cake we're gonna get fat
why it makes the gender stereotypes in
this movie look positively progressive
right um but no it's one of those things
where so this idea of like having
emotions in your hand legs Herman's head
like even back in the 50s they talked
about that quarter right yeah I honestly
I don't care yeah but it's one of those
things where it's been there's a form of
people out there who do apparently that
I don't but but they've done a whole new
twist out and they have done practically
everything that can be done with this
idea and it works for both children and
adults both can watch it and really
enjoy it
uh in my opinion it has the workings of
really a classic family film because
everybody can watch it everybody can get
something out of it it's funny it's
moving it's big shock emotional it's
visually interesting uh but they dive
into really interesting ideas and
visually show up that they also talk
about as well there's no you know it's
never too visual or too talky it's just
a perfect perfect balance and all the
actors are great
uh Amy Poehler I love any boy Lewis
Black is finally used to his potential
in a goddamn movie oh my god is he great
I mean how many times have we seen in a
film and it's just like damn it you're
Lewis Black what the fuck are you doing
in this piece of shit this is finally
here's a film that utilizes a great cast
and he still steals the fucking show
but I'm the enemy animate the mannerisms
that he had well they captured his
mannerisms like hands down it just I I'm
just like wow it's it's creepy he's a
willing a red box with a couple of eyes
yet I'm like still that somehow Lewis
Black yeah they really catch him
perfectly
uh and it shows in my opinion uh you
know not a groundbreaking new lesson but
certainly one you don't see definitely
on children's films but not in many
films either is the importance of
sadness that really is what this film is
about the importance of all your
emotions well not only that but it
was I liked it because it was also the
record Ralph Morel which is um sometimes
you don't get your happy ending so deal
with it yeah and that's it well that's
another great alibi while we talked
about films what do you mean go all the
way with something well what do you mean
you know push it and own it a sub this
is what I'm talking about when a
character dies they die when a character
has to live with a situation it's not
all we get our happy ending
no they live with the situation this is
part of evolving films like this are
more about a catharsis yeah I'm getting
everything you want um which i think is
a much more healthier more but we also
grew up on Don Bluth film so well I
think at some point you leaned over and
you just said you know oh yeah whose
film disguised as a no there's a
particularly um maudlin kind of
melancholy section um that has to deal
with like sacrifices this is bad today I
turned you it I'm just like this is a
dumb blue foam disguised as a Pixar
movie and I'm waiting I told you I was
waiting for that sacrifice to be retcon
I was waiting for it to come back and oh
that sacrifice Ettrick it better but no
you're wrong with you being lost wasn't
really being lost so know what we want
was well yeah well it's okay cuz we
saved the day so everything works out
yes what were they save the day like I
can do please drop but yes the girl goes
insane yeah insolence to you she had
this great jacket in the rubber room
yeah as they're all fighting amongst
each other um no it I was thinking this
I was thinking the same thing I I
thought for sure that that sacrifice was
going to be just kind of undone because
Oh will they save the day and
everything's back to normal and new it's
day and I like photos I mean dark pixel
well this is no but they have the
backing they have they have the balance
to back it up and what's so great about
is it not like oh the sacrifice happened
just because kids films they hear this
is something they need like you know I
can't do better sending like oh we're
putting this in because we hear this is
what epics need no it makes sense both
for the children
watching it and for the adults because
they know this is part of growing up and
how these things do kind of disappear
and these sacrifices do happen and
that's just part of it's part of a -
part of the mental stability and it's
just so clever the way they take some
really well done I mean I think they'd
use the term symbolism but really is for
easy yeah by me they really use it for
you know for these different emotions
and these different stages of growing up
and they totally run with them they go
all the way so that a child can watch
and enjoy all the kind of cool colors of
them turning into the abstract thoughts
but the grown-ups can be like those are
real abstract conditions they're talking
about those are real stats and those are
real levels and when the kid gets older
they can tell I look at and even learn
some of these abstract concepts now see
there's a rant I let you go off on and
now people won't be shitting on you what
not special because it's it's apples and
oranges but you know how you said
Jurassic world made you feel like a kid
yeah yeah watch yeah you know I didn't f
air it out my respect this is the movie
that made me feel like a kid again
how does this this did - yeah this is
totally incredibly joylynn apparent
motion to impress I don't know some but
but this has all the levels of such a
great great creative animated family
film you know yeah and there's already
the very small backlash of how dare
critic change original because her
meager determine shared oh my god okay
first off I regret ever even saying that
cuz I took part in that I saw the
trailer and I thought oh yeah it kind of
reminds me of Herman's head but if
you're still harping on there now that
the movies out it's like just just give
it up you're not doing original every
single person who doesn't like this
movie if it begins with her my GERD it's
not original Herman's head I
automatically just completely ignore the
link or move on to something else and I
was watching a video earlier and
somebody mentioned Herman said and I'm
like oh Christ and it didn't even bother
like ya know HSN owned a you're gonna
let that ruin tail yo sorry
hipster ass you know you weren't the
only ones who sat there and lived
through that decade and actually watched
a few episodes of Herman's head we did
and yes it was a shitty
show though it's actually much funnier
now because it's just so bad it's kind
of funny but ya know just just stop stop
and yes I know this pixel movie coming
out as a Futurama episode and it's fun
to make fun of now but if it comes out
and it's a decent movie just shut up
about it well I mean there we go but but
again this is taking an idea that you
know it has yes has been done and again
I can even point back to that Disney
cartoon years ago I mean this isn't them
the newest idea because it takes ignore
which is in this new direction and does
everything what everything that can be
done with this I when I let us at been
done before what I will say is that well
it's not the most original idea oh my
god there's people running your brain
it's wildly inventive I think that's the
better term to use because what they did
with that idea in running with it is
really inventive and a lot of fun to
watch I liked all the the different
little and spread out I liked how they
represented her core memories and filing
them away and it's the train of thought
ripped up Sharkboy and let it go - so oh
no can't see that's how you do a train
of thought part yeah for in a movie this
movies are you doing Sharkboy and
Lavagirl not so much um I sort of
thought watching I was like this is what
that movie should have been in terms of
time oh no like dreams and thought and
stuff oh no this can be really smart and
really clear you know you want to
example how to do a kid swim and how not
to do kids oh how not to do kids film
Sharkboy and Lavagirl how to do a kid's
film this movie um no but it was wildly
inventive it it was creative just all
the little universes and worlds and ways
of representing they should when they go
into the abstract thought when they go
into those really world let me mom
anymore looks like Hollywood ads don't
go said it's something a particularly
clever I don't mean this in a bad way
it's something a particularly clever kid
would come up with it feels like
something you would see inside a kid's
head not so much in adults but I think
that's why you made me feel like a kid
cuz like who didn't draw images of the
brain you know at some point and like
you know what there's my hair spray
gagged rears and meals and stuff like
that
you know that well we were artistic kids
but maybe not every kid but you know
kids do that sort of thing and they
think like that and I like the fact that
it worked that way versus I think that
this director also did Monsters Inc
didn't he
maybe I'm pretty sure he also did I want
to know read it up the line is the
person who did up and also wreck-it
Ralph but I'm not know like another
director who did wreck a Ralph as well
but I'm not sure I could be wrong um but
but anyway be aware we go I mean this
gets it right where Monsters Inc to me
just didn't then hole like all right I'm
just saying I want a few people who
didn't like monsters in college know I
know I'm a terrible person I have no
soul I think it's okay yeah I don't
think it's fantastic but I think it's
okay
the the baby could be good he says brew
at the end and I'm going I don't she
technically she yes so it the funny
thing is watching Monsters Inc again I
saw it again recently it was running on
one of the station's I that part of it I
don't mind so much even though it really
is fucking babies day out with colorful
monsters um it's that whole side plot
with the corporation though it's
alternate form of energy and and we
don't need to scare kids we do this
completely over kids heads and it
doesn't mesh with anything and I feel
like between this and then up had an
interesting problem which is the first
ten minutes of up maybe one of the best
pieces of cinema ever put to celluloid
ever put to film um and the rest of
movies okay it's the time it's perfectly
good
I really like the rest of them there's
there's nothing wrong with the rest of
the movie but it's like that ten minutes
kind of a if you ask most people what
did you like most about up they'll say
one of two things the first 10 minutes
or squirrel-like it's one of those two
things like nobody like really talks
about the rest of the movie that much so
in a strange way even though that one
part of up there's no moment in this
movie that is as good as that first ten
minutes and up but as an overall film I
actually think this is the better movie
I think it's very Monsters Inc I think
it's better than
up as a complete project there's no
moment as good to me as that first ten
minutes and up but if you ask me which
is the better movie altogether totally
this one like this guy I think finally
has nailed it you know I I was made a
completely whole good movie beginning to
end which is one of Pixar's problems
nobody talks about it much but some of
the ones you know that we remember no
way they're pretty good they're half a
movie wall-e is half a movie and the
first half is one of my favorite films
of all time and the second half I
couldn't give a shit about you know an
up as a known where the first ten
minutes is one of the greatest movies of
all time and the rest of it is pretty
good um you know so and brave was
another one where it starts off kind of
interesting it goes in all sorts of
weird circles and so this really is the
first Pixar movie of this type that I
think really works beginning middle end
perfectly and I thought Toy Story 2 is
pretty oh no I said of this type I'm
talking about you're like up um or the
hell Zeeland when I was just talking
about monsters are wall-e know uh up
wall-e those outside of the Toy Story
realm
um you know probably the best of this
type since finding Nemo or actually know
where I go ratatouille but um but yeah
is so I mean for me it honestly I would
even can make an argument there are a
few scenes I mean for me it's that I'm
still so close to it it's hard to tell
but there are a few scenes I would add
you can argue are just as good as that
opening 10 minutes because you kind of
know where it's going you know that it's
somehow it's gonna teach us very
important lesson that you need sadness
that sadness is important uh which is a
sense no this is such a graphic time for
that message now honestly I think with
the social media and everything I think
so many people have gotten so sucked
into the online world and sometimes
their emotions can just leave everything
I mean and they don't have much control
because there's not much consequences
and so the emotions take over and
there's not too much thought sometimes
and that's not everybody but you all
know you've seen those people and this
is something where for years hon years
I'd be growing up and everybody has been
taught sadness is kind of a bad thing
you don't want to be too sad and you
don't but you also don't want to be too
happy either and you don't want to deny
reality and they show the usefulness and
the importand the way they rarely said
well that was the way they represent
that was so clever because I I swear to
God I was sitting there thinking for the
first half of this movie I got I got
completely wrapped up into and I'm like
fucking sadness stop me you know I by
the end of it you know you you get to
the moral and like yeah I guess there is
a use but like they really suck you in
and you get this like because anything
she's got like this and that says like
this Midas touch and anything she
touches like turns to sand is and you're
completely wrapped up in the story
you're like will you stop touching
things I really wish I could have seen
this film maybe eight or nine years
earlier honestly because they even
though it's like a nude I totally agree
even though I knew like sadness was
important and everything and it's good
to accept it's good to more and it's
good to everything there was always this
part of me that has got me in trouble
before where I sort of was like if I'm
just happy enough beaten optimistic
about everything like it's okay and if I
can make them happy enough even up this
degree you know it's okay if I make the
person I'm talking to happy upbeat
everything will be alright and sometimes
you just need that acknowledgement that
something bad has happened or you're
going through something really emotional
or tough and you just need to be there
you need to acknowledge that this is a
sad moment and I really guess what as
far as shows yeah this is what that film
shows in such a brilliant way uh the
scene that really got me the most I
won't give it away too much but it's
when Joy's looking at this ball I don't
think it was a core memory but it was
you know a happy memory and she rewinds
it and I won't go any more than that but
that really is the scene where I'm like
god that just so fucking brilliantly
Yost's the importance of sadness it was
a it was a big reveal and it again it
reminded me of the record Ralph Morrill
it's more about having a catharsis in
being okay with yourself and letting you
know
emotions go versus you know just getting
everything you want um cuz at the end
you know life doesn't always work that
way and you just have to just frickin
deal with it um but to your point about
the any scenes as good as up um if I'm a
match and I would it's very good it's
totally to tell em hmm
no there's some jutsu there is there's a
lot I have no problem but it with this
movie but there's a lot of hyperbole
going on because I there's a lot of
people like I know Richard Roper just
came out he's like this may be one the
best films of the decade and this is
certainly the best film of the year so
far a night we've got another friend
who's a local critic and he's like well
the greatest films ever made
I'm not saying them wrong I feel like I
need to penalize yeah yeah yeah like I
don't really want to like make big
proclamations particularly cuz I don't
want to oversell it cuz if I'm just like
maybe one of greatest movies ever make
witness movies at the decade with if I
oversell they feel like people are gonna
walk on the India way back like yeah
thinking it's an immediately backlash
and I hope they don't because the the
other strange thing about this movie is
the trailer blew I mean that was it yeah
oh this will you know I mean everyone
else was like oh he said you were right
I thought maybe you're right and I'm
like you know what maybe I'm the only
one and then I went online and I was
talking of talking about how good the
film was yeah everyone said oh the
trailer doubtful I had so many people
like really this look like shit from the
trailer so whoever is marketing this you
suck it
no no but think about it I mean every
Pixar movie has you know pretty much
been ahead and like honestly I'm just
every Pixar trailer I've ever seen look
awful I've never seen a Pixar trailer
I'm like ooh I'm excite a see this is
where the first one I was excited for
because they Jam whose time I was
excited for wall-e I was excited for up
um fucking excited as hell for brave and
elephant that was don't let death I
think about how see you'll know what I
got excited for thus yeah but but this
trailer I just I'm just like
like what they I I where we thought oh
Christ here we go again Pixar's decline
their continuing yeah like and I'll be
the first to admit holy shit how wrong I
was
um this don't believe that if you
thought the trailer was suck don't
believe the trailer oh yeah it was
really better than it looks and I have
no problem admitting that cuz I thought
this was gonna suck you know was
something that uh I was saying is that
because I can I can see someone going in
and being like well ok it's good but I
wasn't quite as sucked in its like
everyone else's like honestly I can see
that the one thing that I think I really
have to just say I mean hands down this
is probably one of the best written
script I've you know seen in years
yeah I mean they're just on paper this
is fuckin ingenious there's like Rotten
Tomatoes at sitting at 98% there's like
for critics for who are giving negative
reviews and god bless you because I
don't think you're gonna be able to walk
out and say um but yeah one of them was
talking about like it's just not a good
script I'm like did we see the same
movie yeah that I can there's a couple
that are very legitimate reviews I my
guys are you're coming from I disagree
vehemently but there's a couple though
where I'm just like no I'm like you
couldn't have seen this there's no way
and it was like yeah the script the
comedies lame the script is lame I'm
like what I just couldn't wrap my head
around it I was like cuz we laughed hard
yeah it's really hard and I won't say
not if not as much as say like you know
a toy store oh it's not a laugh a minute
yeah but when it hit everything run so
quickly it's this is the first movie in
a while I can think of where when they
said we're going to Imaginationland or
we're going to Dreamland or we're going
to the subconscious
I was excited oh my god what are they
gonna do with this and they didn't
disappoint they did so cleverly and each
one had their own identity to the world
and their own and Billy was so creative
and this is despite the fact I just say
it and this is on me so don't take this
as a criticism like I think Pixar
Animation sucks in some cases it's I
cannot stand this overly cutesy pastel
hewed production design on some of these
films and I do like I said oh well time
looking directly at you monsters ink and
bugs life and that sort of thing like
some of them I just I can't do it as on
me I'm not saying that
Oh Pixar you suck like but it's not it's
not my cup of tea
um and that was one of my worries when I
saw the trailers I'm like oh these
colors is a pastel again this looks kind
of like monsters ink kind of again and
it's very cutesy production design um so
the fact that it had that and I still
loved this movie despite the fact that
when it comes to the art design it's
nothing that really would have
interested me at least on the outset is
saying a hell of a lot it's a very well
put together film yeah uh and the
production design like don't if the the
character design makes up for it in the
animation if if you just showed me those
characters when I saw them in the
trailer was like they almost look lazy
almost look lazy and I don't want to say
that because the animation on them
though is amazing the animation on
sadness particularly I thought with
sunglasses on anger on all of them is
amazing when they're actually animated
but the character designs themselves
don't do anything for me but when they
start moving and talking and have to
engage in the the comedy really really
really good you know and the length of
the not just the worlds themselves but
even like the area that they layout to
control the brain like you know and
control the mind to make the emotions
and stuff you know I'm watching this I'm
thinking like I love this now cuz I'm
looking at all the tentacles I know it's
like when
her anger was about to take control key
summited by hitting the panel these two
levers always come up and that is how we
sing though that's how we drove and
every single time that a Joey would
drive you know she's sort of swirled
this little ball and you know and that
would work there was always something
unique to every person they each had
this distinct so a steering wheel this
way of doing it and if I was a kid I
would love that because I think is the
same thing with like the Studio Ghibli
films a Miyazaki I loved seeing how
things work and I think a lot of kids do
and it makes a world feel more real
there's a respect for how the machinery
works in this I mean even though it's
it's the brain or whatever there's a
real and you're right it rides me of
Miyazaki where it's like you get the
feeling of the gears in the wheel and
the lever sound yeah it all is it that
this was planned out and the amount of
effort that went into this is kind of
mind-boggling
um yeah uh so I don't know it's
definitely that it's hard to say if it
would be my favorite Pixar film of all
time again we're too close I'm really
considering it but I always you it's I'm
a little fun saying this it's in my top
five easily yeah um and it's certainly
like it's certainly the best since Toy
Story three it blows the hell we had
Cars two monsters universe on stirs
University and then freakin brave out of
the water I mean it's it's no contest
those films are jokes freaking jokes
compared to this um so it but they
really enacted a these films and
monsters you big deal oh it's a classic
just it can everyone that like monsters
you can you see this don't believe so
you can see what I'm talking about some
a people are like how dare you come down
a monster as you oh no no you know what
you know if I just please this is what
I'll talk about what I'm looking for
something great from Pixar and
challenging and new and fantastic and
wonderful it's just moving and
everything this this is what I'm talking
about weight everything jokes alone is
enough to do it for me you have to be
good but yeah I will say this I somebody
had the best replied which was what
fucking loved all three of those movies
and now I'm gonna go see this one do
that yes I don't care you like
the movies just go see yes one go see it
yeah so I you know Pixar's back in the
bet you know what the absolute best
thing I could say about this film is
when brave won the Academy Award I just
pitched a shit fit I'm like are you
fucking kidding me like this
Gandhi Academy Awards are more of a joke
every year well they've always been a
joke but III just couldn't believe it if
this wins Academy Award this year I
won't be complaining I don't care I
don't care if you did an animated
version of shit wish list at least I'd
be like well at least this was a really
really good movie so I mean that the
last thing I'll say honestly is that
this is one of the rare films and
sometimes Pixar has done this and I love
feeling it again
it's one of those films that actually
does show me the power of film
it shows what you can do with the visual
medium that also incorporates sound
incorporates incredible creativity
incorporates thought incorporates
character incorporates great story and
it feels a lot of feel it's it just
feels like it's all there uh it feels
like a movie where I'm just like if
there's anything I don't like is the
most extreme level of nitpicking I mean
I think the one thing s is the clown
Cabello scarier oh yeah that's about it
like the climbs could've been citerior I
was strangely just slightly in a way
that in the guy's head it's all sports
related the girl said is like the his
wife said is all thinking about like
some Brazilian hunkers I'm I'm like wow
okay I think this film got really
suddenly sexist at it over but I will
say this though it's equal opportunity
like they apparently both the insides of
their heads are pretty fucking well
maybe like I've loved a they had some
good jokes with it so why would I like
but then you've got that girl's a hockey
player and stuff like no I just you know
it was just weird
I'm gonna take I'm gonna go down now you
can make home no if you if you all go
that route you can make the joke about
like you know when she bumps into the
boy at the end which I won't give it
away cuz it's probably the funniest joke
in the movie but you could be on those
oh really yeah but it's like it's it's
just doing the Mary
broad strokes as I said it's a nitpick
like it I'm not I'm didn't wreck
anything it was that was the only
nitpicky thing where I'm just like yeah
I if I had to grab desperately at straws
to come up at that was my only moment in
the film where I was taken out of bed
and then I can't really say that we'd
have to go to the spoiler corner it was
um one other very small nitpick but um
so yeah there's how much this is the
closest thing to a perfect Pixar movie
we've had in years at least I know some
people think Toy Story 3 is perfect um I
have issues I mean it's good I like it
but okay is issues I think it's a great
movie I know it's a it's perfect Doug
has more issues than I do with it but it
definitely the closest thing to a
perfect Pixar movie since Toy Story 3 if
you think that movie's perfect other
thing anyways gonna say cars too perfect
yeah I said for me I say at least
minimum top three for me yeah for a bet
I mean we're in bread we're basically
Brad Bird territory in the original Toy
Story yeah and Finding Nemo
like that that set of the the first two
Toy Story movies fighting Nemo the Brad
Bird films it's it's in that caliber I
like it when I see a film that's really
really built up and has a lot of hype
and it's like it delivers and it's like
saying you know what they're right and I
can see where they're coming from and
it's maybe the first one that truly
delivered yeah at least this year ya
know it's uh
Jurassic world for me was fun but I ya
know like I said I mean this is a film
that really shows me like you know that
this is why I love film it's movies like
this uh it's like medicine for the Soul
it restores your faith in cinema of it
and Pixar yeah so um yeah really really
good school go see it yeah definitely
check it out and if you hate it then you
saw nothing so we'll see you guys next
time
later